have you seen this [ __ ] that
documentary the inventor with Elizabeth
Holmes no oh what's it on it's on HBO oh
say no more fm mmm dude so check her out
first first first bring her up maybe and
just that just if you could so she I
remember 19 years old starts a company
it goes up to ten billion dollar ember
ten billion dollars she's gonna take a
tiny vial at the old your plate head yep
I'm gonna take a droplet of blood this
big and put it into a machine called the
Edison I'm gonna and we put in the
Machine and it's gonna give you our full
readout you can do it at home a whole
Dunham it will give you all full run
that sold to Walgreens and we will tell
you everything you need to know about
your health in a droplet of blood okay
never mind that's impossible for a
thousand physiological reason sold it
Bill Clinton interviewed er bring up
Clinton interviewing Elizabeth Holmes
wait how does no scientist go well
that's not well so ready so this is the
greatest thing about it so here she is
Steven jobs is her fan she wore the same
outfit every day so she didn't have to
think about anything else and she's
there oh you mean she has no style
that's what that means well did she did
no clue Steven jobs did that Steven jobs
Oh joke this head on that's great yeah I
got one better
no chill square that square said I've
ever seen in my life
well he's a human leg go bring her up on
the TED Talks I want to hear talk just I
want him to hear her voice
I remember briefly but some there's
something bad bad around her right I'll
tell you oh I'll tell you so anyway she
starts this company at 19 years old she
raises 10 it's a 10 billion dollar
company right there 10 billion dollars
all right she she she's got everybody on
her board the individual in changing
outcomes no unless see I'm I dig in it
have access to do so she just dressed
like Bruce Wayne to lower her voice
right to protect the rate to protect and
well-being the well-being
every person smart girl though
calculators we love killer oh why
because she had everybody to dick off so
ok so that's good so now check this out
so she's a superstar she's in every man
this is ten years she creates theranos
in Silicon Valley right near Tesla she's
got she's got the advisors the initially
the guy who was the first investor in
Skype Tesla Airbnb Twitter other this
huge better
he was like his daughter went to school
with her and at Princeton
so she drops out of her hands and he's
like all of us in your company you're a
visionary everybody's involved right
next thing you know there's this there
this it's a it's a machine it's called
the Edison's this big after Thomas
Edison and I'll say your whole read out
the problem was that it was all under
all this secrecy so you had to go
through five doors and said amazing
doesn't say scientist they're like so
the scientists were all like told what
to do but they can't talk about there
either
all these he's got these powerful
attorneys meanwhile she's trying to make
fake it till she makes it look at how
small that droplet of blood is so all of
a sudden these journalists start doing
things on they go well how does the
machine work well through
miniaturization and southern bagel yeah
but this is comically vague some real
smart people out there man he can't
honey didn't know so this Wall Street
Journal [ __ ] and investigative
journalists because I smell [ __ ] I
smell [ __ ] long story short that
company was a huge sham it was all fate
they'd be allowed in the scientists the
scientists were like you want us to tell
people this stuff but we're I can't do
this this machine's not working
none of that knew how the machine was
working I know this isn't working people
were getting other labs that mystery but
they were and the whole house this woman
so happened to all she had 700 employees
all credible scientists one guy like
killed himself because he didn't want to
he didn't he - he's people he's just
found out that it was all [ __ ] and
he's gonna have to go testify
holy was this greatest documentary ever
well dude you got to see it meanwhile
that that woman is going to jail now I
believe for life no life does she
deserve life yeah why cuz she's a huge
scam artist and she was using real
people and using real patients she's
kind of a [ __ ] life Toby 20 years a
fine of 200
dollars each count of wire from she's
potential 2.25 million dollars horror
and economies worth billions
sprite balls not anymore exactly zero
she's got no money she's she was just a
shyster Wow
but man did she really just run there
she had a good run
yeah my popping bottles and [ __ ] yeah
wow it sounds like his great documentary
did you see the one on there uh nuh I
love you now die know about the girl her
boyfriend and he want to commit suicide
she texts them text them into it and he
does it and she's under and they go to
court did she act did she murder him I
love you now die it was what's the most
nine disturbing things I think it's what
do you think be sold on let me let me
just paint the picture here before you
did your on that last document for me I
don't need to see it no it was for you
well now you covered every I'm good now
though this one's same thing 2014 I
think that should happen so I'll cover
so you don't have to watch it so this
Michelle Carter she's kind of like she's
super neat he has no friends really she
meets this boy on family vacation they
live like I don't know a few hours away
from each other they start texting they
get in a relationship
homeboy has tried to commit suicide four
times before I'm ever meeting her he
suffers from it and he would they would
go back and forth and he would almost
harass or with his with his depression
and like with commit suicide and so she
thought she was helping him by tell him
to do it she's like well if this all you
want [ __ ] dealing bears no
responsibility don't think so no I do
that's that's what that's what the court
and the the Boston legal system deal
with because I think is bazan because
Boston Massachusetts because they were
trying to figure out like is she the
reason why commit suicide the parents
blamed her everyone blame her
this kid was clinically depressed and
had a major problem what Fort Totten
what don't blame somebody who was
probably really fed up and like Jesus
Christ dude do it already if you keep
[ __ ] talking to me about this or
whatever it is it is it she's allowed to
say whatever the [ __ ] she wants I mean I
but is is the same as like if you tell
me you're gonna
if you're a child this you're a child
and you do that but if you're an adult
if you're a consenting adult and you're
influenced by that I don't know how you
hold this other person accountable cuz
you don't know what the context was
right she might be a sized sociopath or
she might have been really frustrated
and been like no Shai this she's she I
think it was both I think it was both
because yeah because she was like hey
when you die can can I tell everyone
like you were my boyfriend and he's like
yeah sure and then she like held this is
so [ __ ] up she held like like a
fundraiser but in her home town and all
his friends like why the [ __ ] you do it
there she's like well cuz all my friends
are here you know not his hometown so
she just wanted to like get Fame up yeah
I mean so so what we're doing is we're
we're we're blaming her for murder
because she's not sensitive she may not
have loved the guy anymore
she made her decide this guy's a [ __ ]
mess and I just can't do this and I'm
not in love and I know I don't like this
but it was also what he wanted you know
I'm saying but this is where it's not
you can't save somebody I try to say
look I all due respect to everybody
who's committed suicide in their
families cuz it's horrible
I tried to save somebody from committing
suicide but they want to do it then they
did it right and they did it and I
really tried I [ __ ] tried and it was
awful and I've never told the story and
I and I don't just because it doesn't
matter but the point is is that I
remember thinking to myself and I said
to my friend I said I did everything I
could and my friend said you know you
there's nothing you can do and it's
really hard sometimes but that's like me
trying to save my girlfriend from being
a drug addict it's like you trying to
stop me from eating carbs I can't do not
not happen yes I can try man so you know
do you that what do you think what's
your take on this you some documentary
yeah I don't you definitely shouldn't go
to prison but I think did she got it
yeah she did a year and a half not
terrible kind of slap on the wrist she
got way hotter does she got can eat
anymore but but hey but she uh
so big ha hey buddy hey hurts but here's
the thing is he so he gets he does it he
puts the thing the ventilation into the
truck you know to die that way so
remember this is his fifth attempt now
so he's not very good at so this is his
fifth attempt he does it this way he
gets scared he's gonna die he's
texture-wise doing this he
in the truck so he buys the Moschino
himself she has nothing she don't give
money he does all this himself sets
everything up goes in the truck gets
scared when he's about to commit suicide
gets out of the truck Tech sir I can't
do this
she checked him back yes you can get
back in that [ __ ] truck and then he
does it I still don't think it's I still
don't I call her motivate oh I I still I
still don't think she she has to go do
you think that I don't know that's tough
I mean I really don't know honestly I
don't think I know enough I don't know
if she bears responsibility I don't
think you can it's a very sling zero we
like but is it her spot because she told
the police or the family or I again I
don't know what that relationship was
like right so sometimes it was a cyber
right it was a cyber relation yeah they
might have been in a fight she's nothing
well she's not doing great
you know they plant know she's title no
you know what I mean she messed to he'll
agree I breath she's gonna leave this
[ __ ] everybody
I'm telling cuz she can't eat she was
thick and then she got she's so like
stressed about going to [ __ ] prison
for life she got super thin horrible
what she went through I need that man
and he gets stressed out but III think
it's really easy to try to make somebody
a victim I mean a villain but I this
one's pretty bad but it's a two-part say
she what's the first part it basically
shows how bad she was and I was it goes
but she go to prison for life then see
the second part you see how [ __ ] up he
was yeah and how he's always wanted to
do this and it's his photo she's like
it's a person though she's not good she
wants fame from him commit suicide she
she pretty went missing for like three
days
that's not a jailable offense I know but
listen is B no no that it scalable but
she he went missing for like three days
and then she just to get attention cuz
she don't have any friends I felt bad
for it but she was super needy
just to get attention she told our
friends that he commits suicide so she
did like a trial run to see how it went
she got ton of attention and she holy
[ __ ] he popped up yeah I was like all
preconceived yeah she's got problems
she's got problems but that's all she
has horrible problems well what is what
was she a con with this DC no oh she's
in high school it did yeah I'm like
softball yeah so I
I think this is a tragedy in all cases
all the way around here's the text
message you just need to do it Conrad
the more you push it off the more it
will eat at you you ready and prepared
all you have to do is turn the generator
on and you be free don't spell be like
that and you be free and happy no more
pushing it off no more waiting if you
want it as bad as you say you do it's
time you do it today so that sounds bad
if you don't know the context the
problem is this [ __ ] want it so
bad yeah like he kept trying to do it
she I think - I got alright dude will
[ __ ] do it man like I thought all
this stuff all you want shut the [ __ ] up
about it just do it it's a very strange
case cuz like it's a little different
doctor Kevorkian right because those
people were suffering Oh suffering huh
yeah like and you can't - you can't
break a promise just go in a quiet
parking lot or something and then
nothing she was but she did want it she
sees my back she's trying to do it today
or what she sounds like she has it
sounds like she vanished yeah well she
knows she was get fame from yeah she's a
terrible person she wanted him to dodge
it terrible person so I would say that
she's a [ __ ] or she's a very
confused messed up young lady here the
Tecla just cute look oh here you go and
are you the homeboy well this is 545
they haven't spoke all day he types in
how did you day she is what are you
gonna do
so you'll get snap chained when I sent
them to my day was he good she goes
that's great what did you do and I'm
just going to work a little bit then
look for stuff what are you gonna do it
stop ignoring the question you can't
think about it you just have to do it
you said you were gonna do it like I
don't get why you art because I don't
get it either
I don't know [ __ ] man then she goes so I
guess you aren't gonna do it then no
[ __ ] for you all that for nothing
I'm just confused like you were so ready
and determined alright I mean eventually
he goes I mean I'm gonna get around to
it I don't know what I'm waiting for but
I have everything lined up no you're not
Conrad you predict last night was it you
just kept pushing off and you say you're
gonna do it but you're never gonna do it
it's always gonna be that way if you
don't take action sounds like a
motivator to me you're just making it
hard on yourself by pushing off you just
have to do it do you want to do it now
he goes is it too late
I don't know it it's already light
outside I'm gonna go back to sleep love
you I'll message you tomorrow no it's
probably the best time now because
everyone's asleep just go somewhere in
your truck no one is really out right
now because it's awkward time if you
don't do it now you're never gonna do it
and you can just say you'll do it
tomorrow but he probably won't alibi yo
you awake hours are you gonna do it
today hours like now that person now I
kind of exaggerated some of that test
I just gives you the context she's a
that's bad guy if I were her family if I
was his family I would want her dead all
they do they want her in prison for yeah
but she's but she sounds like a
sociopath who you know it sounds like it
sounds like she was getting off on
having enough power to get somebody to
kill but she's also she it like she even
has a voice in high school she was like
everyone picked on her like she had no
friends so all the kids like she's super
choose to nice there's something wrong
with her oh yeah right I mean so this is
somebody who's got their own mental it's
like the to the the processor and
outside the defense is kind of alibi was
like : if he was gonna he's tried to
commit suicide four times if he was in
commit suicide and she's walking by if
she yelled do it now jump hard as hard
as you can should she go to prison no he
was gonna do it no matter what
yeah but to encourage him to do it I
mean you're not a complete [ __ ] no
no no he's not girl who's here he nor
seventeen
I think she's 16 at that okay so she's a
child
she's she's clearly very some keeps
going down chin her so there's one
really bad something's wrong with her
right something's wrong with her she
wanted attention
look this [ __ ] well she's relentless
yeah he was hey I'm just going on a walk
shoes are you back from your walk he
goes in like five minutes she goes okay
so you're gonna do it yes Jesus I guess
she was what's that means I don't know
I'm freaking out about it you know what
now I'm reading these texts sounds like
he might have not done it if she went in
[ __ ] kept encouraging it so much
right
she's the Tony Robbins a suicide she
just [ __ ] motivate him so much I
don't know I think it drives me crazy
more you just need to work on right all
right I'm gonna do it today you feel bad
for the kid man promise or she ever
shaken and then she's telling where to
go
go somewhere you know where you won't
get taught you can find a place are you
gonna do it now he was I'm determined
and she goes I'm happy to hear that he
was I'm ready good because it's time you
know that when you get back from the
beach you're just gonna go do it it's
the best time to do it
are you back yes no more thinking just
have to do it on my way the Kmart
parking lot there's gonna be no cars
there at 9 so that's where I'll be found
ok perfect when will you be home and
like ten what a sad story like I don't
want to kill anyone else with me you
won't when they opened the door they
won't know it's color swordless you're
overthinking again oof oh wow so this
this is a 16 year old who had no idea
this is all gonna be on the record and
ruined her life and there's something
very your life should be a little ruined
you know I can't do this this is a
mentally unstable girl and and the boy
was unstable these are two very unstable
people Wow I was trying to do it so
she'd get attention how terrible is this
her life he was I just don't know how to
leave the family she goes sagen go the
store
he goes no like I want them to know that
I love them I didn't mean to hurt them
she goes yeah the probably sat for a
while but they get over it
they know you had no other choice she's
a kid though she doesn't know this is
this is sixteen year old baby but this
is my I know that's a defense I wasn't
like that man no one in the room was
like because because you didn't suffer
from some kind of behavioral disorder or
me I don't know dude I think saying that
well they're just the kid they don't
know I disagree so she has 16 I knew not
to drink and drive I knew not to rape
girls I knew if homeboy was gonna commit
suicide I don't talk them into it yeah
you don't saying yeah there's a lost
once he was leaving now okay you can do
this I'm almost there did you delete the
message Conrad Conrad Conrad and the her
next post enjoy the parade from up there
tomorrow Conrad know you would love to
be there each that is just in this [ __ ]
posted I will never understand why this
had to happen
national suicide awareness day I wish
more people understood I love you know
she's she's a terrible person was her
way of becoming popular for once oh
right well that's the documentary
internachi yeah okay she goes prison for
about two years um it's just a bummer
man I think yours is better who's more
sick at the head this your girl is smart
about it who created the Aizen what was
it the Edison - Edison
both [ __ ] yeah again that's not
yours how about you're a long 16 year
old you know how about your girl went to
prison longer though well yeah but this
is a 16 year old so a lot of times
that's taken into account it's very sad
you know that's a bummer Gary there are
a lot of people that dogs don't do it
try to figure out oh well that's gonna
help I'm glad you said that though yeah
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]